Oh
in the clutches of a posse of ladies but
the bosshoss are hardly the good guys
either in the video for das profs the
title track from their new album
vamonos
your family left I Nizam Akula we
thought it'd be a cool mood not to be
the cool boys all the time and das große
is really about being the cool dudes
shall we turn the tables and got us a
couple of ladies wearing the pants I me
aur wasn't unhappy ones leaders have to
hand her boobies by quentin tarantino
and russ meyer served as the videos
inspiration german model francisco Koopa
plays the leader of the cowgirl gang
we've been friends for some years now
and we thought why not ask it she'd be
like doing it supermodels and rock music
videos are an old tradition we had to
pick up on that plane weeks ago they
suddenly asked me if I felt like joining
in and Here I am it might look like a
plains of New Mexico but the shooting
location is an open pit mine in
Brandenburg here the band's hometown
Berlin make up my own more I'm owed
everything down low this morning so the
boys could set up a desert to mankind
before pending the songs for the new
album the two front men took a trip to
Nashville the home of country music here
they met local songwriters and immerse
themselves in the authentic atmosphere
two fish and Esther asleep in doing the
classic Nashville sound for ten years of
course that's where we get our
influences and inspiration you hear
honky tonk everywhere there and you take
a piece home with you doesn't it much
i'm in the hole is it despite a bus this
is the base used in the recording of
Heartbreak Hotel since my baby left the
final new place to dwell it's down in a
row history that was it or something
like that they flew back to Berlin to
record material in their own studio das
brass is their eighth album and it stays
true to the bosshoss sound this is such
it always turns out relatively similar
because it came from one hand or one pen
or one band but we still try to come up
with something new and incorporate new
elements dos bros also has a couple of
new elements and a ton of new songs no a
cut abaya once new songs and sounds are
the main thing
the Magnificent Seven galloped to the
top spot on the German album charts now
the boss hoss on living high on the hog
even if the new video has been working
on the chain gang vamonos